all right good morning everybody welcome
to another episode of Sunday morning
science very excited to be here I've got
kind of a new set up that hopefully will
be helpful I've got my I can see the
live chats over here and I can see these
super chats over there and yeah well
we'll try this out hopefully this will
run a little bit more smooth than last
time last last couple of times I'm very
excited today cuz we're going to talk
about the evolution of new genetic
information and just kind of while
people are trickling in here
I just curious asking you guys go ahead
and respond in the in the comments here
how many of you started following Nancy
after lat last week's show her stuff was
awesome I I just watched her she did a
live periscope she's she uses periscope
to do live videos it was on Twitter that
I saw her just the other day she was
doing something she was doing a video on
the biodiversity of Ecuador and I loved
watching her live stuff she being a
woman on YouTube or you know on the
internet doing live videos there's a lot
harder than being a dude she gets
constantly sexually harassed in the
comments and she just like a boss she's
just she responds to it in really
hilarious ways you should go watch some
of her live videos I thought that was
entertaining she she's talking about
biodiversity and she's responding to
comments since she's just like she's
reading through them kind of mumbling
like I do but not as much as she's
reading and she's just like yeah my
personal life has nothing to do with the
biodiversity of Ecuador I'm she just
constantly uh yeah she's awesome
responding to things being a
thick-skinned really good really good
presenter she's got a really good
personality for this type of work so
anyways you should definitely follow her
sigh bugs on Twitter and if you follow
her on Twitter you'll have her I mean
you'll find her everywhere
she posts pretty much everything on
Twitter anyway we've got about we've got
quite a few people here now so let's go
ahead and dig in let's get started I'm
going to open up my well let me start
sharing my screen here and open my
presentation so today we are going to
take a look at this paper forty years of
in vitro evolution we're gonna be mainly
answering the questions how does new
genetic information evolve this is a
question that comes up quite a bit just
a little reminder here on the left you
can see my contact information on
Twitter I am at stated clearly on
patreon I am patreon.com forward slash
stated clearly and you know today we're
gonna do a lot of Q&A actually there's
two sections of Q&A today like through
the presentation it's kind of a a more
dense presentation I want to make sure
that people are following everything
that I'm talking about super chats our
priority for the the questions because
you know that's awesome I get you guys
you know couldn't give me a little tip
super chat it's the this is a Sunday
morning science chat so it's kind of
like passing around the contribution
plate super chats are you know reminder
to be nice to people in the comments
there's a lot of people with different
views and some people who might be angry
just ignore angry people in the comments
keep things civil keep things PG if
possible I will also try to keep things
PG
so these are the two big questions that
we're going to be talking about today
new genetic information cannot evolve
that's this is the claim that a lot of
sort of uh well-educated well let me
just talk about this for a second here
you know over time as biologists have
found more and more super obvious
evidence for evolution creationists have
creationist who insist on denying the
obvious fact that life on Earth evolved
they've had to kind of resort to more
and more abstract arguments in order to
continue denying the the evidence of
evolution and one of those more abstract
arguments is this idea that no new
genetic information can evolve and this
is something that we see on like
seriously every single creationist
website from Answers in Genesis to
creation.com - there's also a website by
the intelligent design people called
evolution news I thought that's clever
they they bought the URL evolution news
and they put up anti-evolution
propaganda on their super clever but
they they they've gotten several
articles about this idea that no new
genetic information can ever evolve
they're very adamant about this and then
the second big question or big claim
that that you hear from creationists
today is that evolution can't happen
until you have cells and the genetic
code and cells and the genetic code of
course are both very complex and so the
argument there is well you have to have
intelligent design at the start of life
because these things are so complex and
there's two people that are making that
argument Perry Marshall is a friend of
mine I've had him on the show actually
he's one of the people that says that
you can't get evolution to happen
without the genetic code and he wrote a
book about that called evolution 2.0
and I I like Perry marshal a lot again
he and I are friends and we've had lots
of discussions about this in the past
and then there's a guy going around
right now
James tour he's a chemical engineer and
a creationist and he's going around on
this - were talking about the complexity
of the cell and the complexity of the
biochemistry of the cell and he makes
this claim over and over and over again
that you cannot get evolution until you
have the cell and because the cell is so
complex there had to be an intelligent
designer at least at the start of all
this and both both of those arguments
both of these arguments mean genetic
information cannot evolve and evolution
cannot happen until you have cells and
the genetic code both of those arguments
have been thoroughly thoroughly debunked
for 40 years now and we're going to talk
about one series of experiments that has
debunked both of those claims and we can
read about this in this paper called 40
years of in vitro evolution which goes
over a series of experiments on RNA RNA
can actually replicate and evolve given
the right circumstances it can replicate
and evolve without any need for the
genetic code and without any need of the
cell and we're going to talk about these
experiments today they're really
proof-of-concept experiments the the
situations in which these evolve they're
not situations that you would have on
the early earth
these are proof-of-concept people who
are studying the origin of life now are
trying to get similar situations to
happen in a context that would be more
relevant to the environments that
existed on the early earth but yeah for
40 years now we've had this proof of
concept which is absolutely amazing but
before I dig into that paper and I
wanted to respond to a question that I
got last night as I was preparing for
this by YouTube user and follower of the
static casually channel in the stated
clearly Channel his name is Isaac and he
he wrote me this fairly long
question but his main question is how
does a beneficial mutation happen and he
goes on to talk about insulin you know
insulin is this molecule hold on get
drink of water hear my voice
insulin is this very specific molecule
it's a protein so it's a protein that's
coded for by one of our genes we have an
insulin gene and he points out the fact
that if this if this mutates you know
there's actually lots of ways that a
gene can mutate without changing the
structure of the protein so there's a
lot of neutral mutations that can happen
in the insulin gene but he says that you
know if if a mutation in insulin occurs
that does change the protein sequence a
lot of times the person born with that
mutation ends up having diabetes they're
born with diabetes and so he's like how
how can beneficial mutations happen when
proteins are so sensitive to mutations
like this and furthermore he goes on to
say and what happens if two or more
mutations are required before the change
is beneficial you know how is it that
beneficial mutations can occur well here
we have insulin this is this is the
insulin protein and again insulin is
used as a communication molecule it it's
between tissues so different tissues in
the body signal to each other with the
insulin molecule and the insulin
molecule is extremely preserved is what
we say it's it's it's amino acid
sequence so it's protein structure is
extremely preserved across evolutionary
time here on the Left I've got a pig
insulin molecule here on the right I
have a human insulin molecule and you
can see that they are almost identical
there is only one amino acid difference
between the two molecules between humans
and pigs that means that pretty much
every single mutation that has ever
happened in this molecule has been bad
in mammals and actually this
is true not just in mammals but in
vertebrates in general if you were to
look at I don't have the fish protein
here but if you look at the the insulin
molecule in I think it's I think it's a
tilapia that the research has been done
on its it's almost identical to human
insulin and in fact it's so close to
identical that you can actually use it
in the human body and it will work it'll
actually do its job in the human body so
Isaac is right pretty much any mutation
in this protein is bad but that's
actually not super common for proteins
and in many proteins that is not the
case at all and I don't see sorry I got
lost in my notes here yeah so for many
proteins that's not true at all and what
there's there's lots of proteins for
example that we've we watched in dogs
and dogs we have this rapid evolution
right since they're they've been
domesticated we have all sorts of
different weird shapes and sizes of dogs
and we can look at the mutations that
have caused those differences in
phenotype and we can see the proteins
that code for those differences and a
lot of the lot of the proteins that can
easily mutate are things are proteins
that regulate the expression of other
proteins and also the the regulatory
regions of of a gene can also mutate
quite a bit without ruining the protein
so for example in insulin it's it's very
rare for a mutation to survive in the
protein coding region of insulin but
there are lots of mutations lots of
differences if you look at one animal to
another in the in the regulatory region
of the gene that codes for insulin
and mutations in the regulatory region
of insulin will make insulin either
produce more rapidly or more slowly and
it you know different mutations will
change the regulation of this protein
and so those types of mutations
mutations that change the regulation of
a protein those are the main types of
mutations that happen across
evolutionary time I've got a whole video
series on the stated clearly channel
it's actually just two videos but it's
on how does new genetic information
evolve and in that animation series I
give a whole bunch of different examples
of mutations that give that give rise to
new traits and one of the ones that I
focus in on is there is the the cane
toad which I believe is native to
Australia don't quote me on that though
I talked about it in the video it has a
toxin that it produces that messes with
a protein called the the the blonde
gotta look this up in my notes the
sodium potassium ion pump so it creates
a protein that messes with that pump it
trips up that pump blocks it from from
being being useful in the animal that
eats the toad or gets swallows any of
this poison and in most animals that
will kill them it'll cause seizures and
stuff and then they'll die if they
swallow too much of it but there's lots
of animals that have evolved an immunity
to it lots of predators of the cane toad
that have eventually evolved an immunity
to this and they've done that because
this paper right here talks about the
specific mutations that can cause this
immunity there's a whole bunch of
different types of mutations that can
cause this immunity and they act in an
additive function so if you have one of
these mutations you're sort of immune to
the the cane toad you can swallow a
little bit of it and at least survive
and if you have multiple mutations you
get to the point to where the cane toads
toxin is pretty much useless against you
you're pretty much invincible to it and
this happens we now know exactly what
types of mutations can do this again
multiple different types of mutations
can give you a resistance to the cane
toad and they're additive and they can
happen in any sequence you know one can
happen first then the other there's like
12 different kinds that can happen and
this this is more typical of the types
of mutations that we actually see they
give rise to you know beneficial
phenotypes
it's very common I the second animation
that I have on the evolution of new
genetic information talks about gene
duplication events gene duplications are
another way in which new genetic
information evolves and I talked a lot
about this mutation of a new toxin in in
snakes there was a toxin that they have
that allows them to cause rapid clotting
in their victims and the the clotting
toxin which is expressed in their venom
gland by the way a snake's venom gland
is a modified saliva gland and that
toxin actually comes from a gene that
they normally use in their their own
blood clotting system so snakes their
blood clots when they get cut just like
ours does and actually uses most of the
same proteins this is a protein system a
blood clotting system that first evolved
in in earlier early vertebrates actually
it started evolving before vertebrates
for a thing and our ancient ancient
ancestors Precambrian this thing started
but it really solidified in early
vertebrates so all fish share a very
similar blood clotting system to us and
these snakes share a very similar blood
clotting system and what happened in
these snakes is there was a gene
duplication in
of the proteins that causes blood
clotting that that duplication occurred
and the duplicated gene was inserted in
a segment of the snake's genome that
allowed it to be expressed in the venom
gland and so these snakes were now
excreting this blood clotting protein
into their venom gland and so when they
would bite an animal it would it would
rapidly clot at the site of the site of
the bite and this clot could form could
cause problems it was it was there's so
much of this clotting factor that was
injected into the body of the animal it
actually helped kill them and further on
further mutations in the duplicated
version of the gene that's now expressed
in their saliva gland for the mutations
that made it more and more efficient and
now what happens when you get bit by one
of these snakes it has this gene in its
venom glands what happens when you get
bit by the snake is you will rapidly
clot at the side of the bite and you
will clot so quickly that all the
clotting factors in your entire body
will get used up right at the site
you'll get a huge nasty clot right at
the side of the bite and everywhere else
your clotting factors are so used up
that you start bleeding from all the
little Nicks and scrapes that you have
on your body and the internal Nicks and
scrapes that you have within your own
circulatory system you will actually
bleed to death internally because of
this snake bite
it's kind of it's crazy you know you
have because you're clotting so fast in
one area you bleed out and the rest of
your body horrible horrible way to go
but yeah this is how one of the many
ways that we have discovered that new
genetic information evolves new
beneficial mutations arise is you have a
a gene duplication event and that
duplicated gene then undergoes point
mutations it's free to undergo point
mutations because it's not it's no
longer crucial for your survival and
reproduction because you don't have two
genes so that original gene continues to
do its function and this new gene is
freed up to mutate and and that's one
way that these highly specific proteins
can gain new new functions so there is
this paper on that the the nature
education website so nature magazine is
a scientific the nature journal is a
scientific journal but they also have
this kind of public facing side their
nature education series and on there
they have though they'll have authors
write to the public so they kind of
simplify their research there's this
wonderful paper sorry there's just
wonderful paper on the the origin of new
genes and you can read that on there it
does a really good job over viewing the
research I mean it's kind of a little
bit old now it was written in 2008 so
there's a lot of new stuff that we have
now particularly on the evolution of
genes de novo so something that I don't
talk about in my video series on the
evolution of new genetic information I
don't talk about de novo origination of
genes but what can also happen is we
have large stretches of our DNA that are
not used for for producing RNA or
protein and mutations in these this not
these non-coding regions some people
call it junk DNA it's not really junk
DNA it's actually it does do stuff but a
lot of it does not all of it some of it
is truly just junk DNA but a lot of it
is used for things but mutations in this
so-called junk DNA can cause a stretch
of DNA to start being transcribed into
RNA and that RNA can have can end up
having a useful function a lot of times
it just ends up being kind of noise
inside the cell but a lot of times these
these mutations can give rise to actual
functional sequences and so that is
another way that new genes come about
there's a lot of research on that
happening right now because it's not a
process that we understand very well
there's a lot of research happening on
that
now if you do a Google search for de
novo gene evolution you'll find a whole
bunch of different papers on that and
again this is new there's a lot of
debate and discussion about how this
actually occurs and but yeah what we do
know that it happens so I want to just
kind of field some questions now looking
at the super chat section and I'm
looking at now at the just the regular
chat as well let me stop sharing my
screen here this is the fun part of the
podcast where I fumble with buttons
[Music]
there there's me again
let's see looking through your questions
Shannon who else loves science Sunday if
you've asked questions again I'm
reacting here and I'll be able to see
them
someone says you should
a co-host you know I you know last time
we had I had Nancy on and it was really
helpful because we could both kind of
you know read questions as we went that
was pretty awesome but yeah I should get
a co-host huh
[Music]
so as I guess it will happen
automatically essentially I'm not sure
what you mean by that sorry okay so
you're saying that regulatory protein
does not need to be turned on to a
corresponding junk DNA stretch in order
to transcribe the junk DNA into an RNA
strand okay so so yeah so Isaac yes
mutations in the the genome within
within a stretch of junk DNA mutations
in that can cause it to attract what we
call regulatory factors regulatory
proteins so it's just just simple
mutations in the actual DNA strand can
attract transcription factors
transcription factors are the proteins
inside the nucleus of the cell in
eukaryotes that attach to a chunk of DNA
and essentially tell the nucleus hey
this chunk of DNA is important we should
transcribe this into RNA and those
transcription factors all they do is
they bind to specific sequences of DNA
so any mutation that causes a stretch of
DNA to look like a lip to attract those
proteins will cause that stretch of DNA
to start being transcribed into RNA and
that RNA molecule might end up doing
something useful it might end up just
being noise inside the cell and actually
might end up being toxic so the the
Reese
on the evolution of new genes is is
looking at that sort of thing and then
further mutations can actually cause
that to be to actually be used by the
ribosome and read out as a protein so
the again a lot of that research is new
but there's a lot of it out there so
yeah check out that the paper that I
showed you that kind of gives an
overview of all of this research is a
good place to start that that that
nature paper review and then you can go
from there and find all sorts of
research done on this it's really cool
all right I think that that answers the
questions that people had about this so
I'm hoping that everything you just said
was follow if if you've been following
my website for a while or my my youtube
channel for a while if you watch the
what is DNA then you know if you watch
the what is the RNA world hypothesis
video hopefully everything I just said
made sense I'm gonna kind of review
things a little bit because the paper
that we're gonna go over is fairly
complex you have to have a pretty good
understanding of what DNA is how it
works so let me just share my screen
again share pull this up again
but just a super quick overview and
again I'm assuming that you've already
watched my what is DNA video or you
already know what DNA is and how it
works but in modern cells today DNA you
could essentially say that it produces
RNA that's not totally true there's
proteins inside the nucleus of the cell
that read DNA and produce a chain of RNA
that's a copy of a certain stretch of
DNA that chain of RNA then goes into the
nucleus of the cell it connects with a
ribosome and the ribosome attaches to
the RNA reads the sequence in the RNA
chain three letters at a time and uses
that to create a protein and it uses so
this is this by the way is a legitimate
communication system that is evolved
between the genome and the ribosome and
I've actually got on the 8th of October
on the non-sequitur show which is
another YouTube channel I will actually
be doing a debate as to whether or not
this is a legitimate communication
system and whether or not we should
consider it a legitimate code because we
call this the genetic code right this
this here is the kind of the cheat sheet
to the genetic code
scientists cracked the genetic code in
the late 60s early 70s and we've we've
called it the genetic code since we
cracked it and there are some biologists
that don't really understand coding very
well but they'd say that this is not
really a genetic code it just is sort of
similar to one it's an it's an analogous
to one I will be arguing that it is
really a code and by a code I mean it is
it is a series of rules that govern a
legitimate communication system and that
communication system is the
communication that exists between the
genome and the ribosome and yeah I will
be making a case that this is a
legitimate communication system
illegitimate code
and why that is yeah so Dean's give rise
to chains of RNA RNA is then read by the
ribosome to produce proteins a specific
shape of protein by reading the code on
the RNA chain and that's a complicated
communication system and there are a lot
of people that like Perry Marshall for
example says that that communication
system had to have been created by an
intelligent designer
this is not the case we know how
communication systems evolve there are
lots of communication systems that have
evolved in biology we just talked about
insulin for example insulin is a
communication molecule it's a different
type of communication that happens in
biology it's a communication molecule
that that's used between different
tissues in our bodies but there are also
examples of communication systems like
the one between flowers and bees for
example a highly complicated
communication system that evolved and
the genetic code this communication
system that we find inside the cell it
is also an evolved communication system
and the evolution was happening before
we had the existence of the genetic code
evolution was already happening in this
paper right here 40 years of ant Mitra
Revolution which we're about to look at
this paper outlines research that
demonstrates that evolution can't happen
without the genetic code so any
questions on that before I dig in
and again if you can do a at stated
clearly in your question it makes it way
easier for me to see on the the live
chat here there's a lot to read through
someone says isn't a communication
system of insulin a product of DNA yes
it is
so insulin is produced by a gene which
we find in DNA there within biology
there are communication systems upon
communication systems upon communication
systems there's any time you get
symbiosis so the evolution of two or
more organisms working together you by
default get a communication system that
evolves between those two entities and
the genes in our genome are
communicating with each other they're
cooperating with each other and so there
is communication between them the when
when we evolved multicellular organisms
when that first started happening again
we had the evolution of a community a
new communication system between cells
and insulin is an example of that the
communication system between cells so we
see every time there's the evolution of
symbiosis there is also the evolution of
communication between the two organisms
that are cooperating again a lot of
people find it weird to think of genes
as organisms but they really are that
this should be thought of as organisms
evolution and its most fundamental level
happens at the level of a gene and these
genes are cooperating with each other
and they really do evolve sort of on
their own in an organism you know
they're they're locked in cooperation so
they can't evolve completely
independently of each other but they do
they do evolve and they sometimes they
compete with each other a little bit
sometimes yeah there's all sorts of
really crazy things that happen when you
follow the evolution of individual genes
you'll see that alliances new alliances
are sometimes made within the genome
certain genes get kicked out across
evolutionary time and all of this is
happening automatically just through the
process of descent with modification
acted upon by selection it's really
really fascinating to get a really good
overview of how that works and how to
start thinking of evolution at the
perspective of a gene I highly recommend
Richard Dawkins book The Selfish Gene
that's where you know he's the one who
really first made the case not not first
made the case but strongly made the case
in a way that the public could
understand that we should be looking at
evolution from the perspective of a gene
he kind of oversold that idea in his
book he was fighting against people that
were saying we should look at the group
or we should look at the species for
where evolution actually happens and and
there actually are legitimate reasons to
look at the group and the species
looking at the group is we don't
understand how to look at the group very
effectively right now but there are some
researchers that are trying to figure
out how to do that better anyway it's
kind of an ongoing argument in biology
when is it most appropriate to look at
genes rather than organisms rather than
populations but there are a lot of weird
questions that we have in biology that
are best answered by looking at the
evolution of individual genes
okay Brian Stephen says look up poke
poke so okay you're out here I'm going
Brian my definition of communication
system is different he says you will if
you watch on the on the 8th you'll
you'll hear what a communication system
how communication system is defined in
by a specialist to study communication
and the genetic code the communication
that happens between the genome and the
ribosome is definitely a legitimate
communication system
someone says this is off topic but do
you think that modern-day scientists
jumped the gun when naming Adams Adams
elementary particles are what the Greeks
probably thought of as atoms yes
John Dalton thought that the atom was
was a fundamental particle and he was
wrong they are not fundamental particles
but yeah I'm I'm going to be debating
Steve McRae who's also a really cool guy
on the 8th so yeah good go watch that
that'll be fun ok so let's get to the
paper here actually let's not get to the
paper quite yet I need to before the
paper is gonna make any sense to people
so many windows I need to talk about RNA
so hopefully most of you have already
watched my video on the RNA world
hypothesis but I'm betting that some of
you have not or if you have it's been a
while right so this is a clip from the
RNA world hypothesis video and the RNA
world hypothesis is this this idea that
the first evolving entities before we
had cells before we had proteins the
first evolving entities were chains of
art of RNA
excuse me my voices waning here the the
there are lots of reasons for this which
you can learn about my watching my video
what is the RNA world hypothesis but RNA
is a really fascinating because it can
actually reproduce and evolve almost on
its own we have we have to set up a
really clean environment for it to
reproduce and evolve and we have to add
into that environment some sort of a
catalyst that can help it reproduce and
we don't yet know the catalysts that we
use right now are they're fairly complex
enzymes they're proteins and we don't
yet have
we haven't yet found a catalyst that
would have existed on the early earth
and we don't yet have an environment
that would have existed on the early
earth so we're really just doing these
experiments as a proof-of-concept right
now so we have not demonstrated that the
RNA world is how things actually evolved
on the early Earth but where we're
getting closer and closer to doing that
well we're getting closer and closer to
demonstrating that the RNA world could
have been a way that life evolved on the
early earth but this this segment of the
video shows how this replication happens
so you've got a chain of RNA and hit
play here it's floating around on the
water here there are free RNA
nucleotides in the water and you'll see
that they will base pair with their
partners and if they base pair with
their partners they form a complementary
strand and if that complementary strand
is then bound together its backbone is
sewn together and we need a catalyst to
do this you get an actual complementary
strand and then as the the temperature
and the water changes you get the two
strands to separate and then if it cools
down again you get base pairing once
more and so through this process you get
RNA replication and through this process
mutations can crop up and because of
that these chains of RNA can change in
their shape over time and in the RNA
world video I show that not only can
chains of RNA base pair with a replicate
through base pairing but they can also
base pair with themselves and what
they'll do is they'll Bend and kind of
fold and stick to themselves and form
these really weird complex
three-dimensional structures and it's
those weird complex three-dimensional
structures that can have functions they
can act they can actually act as enzymes
they can do all sorts of weird things
excuse me drink water here they can do
all sorts of
things in their environment and some of
those things can be highly functional so
this paper that we're looking at here
pull that up 40 years of an vitro
evolution talks about experiments that
we did on the evolution of RNA in the
test tube we've been doing this for over
40 years now really good paper just in
case you're not really familiar with how
scientific papers work most scientific
papers are just people reporting on
experiments that they have done and then
every once in a while someone will write
an overview paper like this you know a
lot of the experimental papers people
aren't really presenting their final
conclusions about things they're
presenting their tentative conclusions
they're describing their experiments and
there's a lot of debate about the
legitimacy of those experiments and and
the legitimacy of the conclusions that
the researchers based on those
experiments so for the most part when
you when you read the scientific
literature you're kind of reading the
middle of an argument a lot of people
assume that if it's published in a
peer-reviewed journal that means it's
legitimate science that means it's a
legitimate conclusion that's that's not
the case the scientific literature is
where scientists argue their their
points and their conclusions but every
once in a while you'll get a paper like
this which is a review of all of the
research in a field and all of the
arguments that have been made in that
field and they're really cool to read
and this one happens to be particularly
easy to read and understand if you have
a good understanding of how RNA
replicates and evolves and you can get
that that idea by watching my RNA world
video so the introduction of this paper
just kind of goes over how evolution
works in general Darwinian evolution
descent with modification acted upon by
selection and it talks about how RNA
actually can evolve through this process
and again RNA does can evolve without
any need of the genetic code without any
need of the cell we can get it to evolve
in vitro so in the
test tube section - he talks about the
first RNA evolution experiment and what
we did is we found this really crazy
virus hold on that's the wrong one
there's really crazy virus you can see
it right here it's called the Q beta
virus and it infects bacteria and it
does not have DNA at all
doesn't use DNA at all instead it just
has RNA what it does is it will infect a
bacterial cell it'll get inside of it it
will excrete its RNA into the bacterial
cell and that RNA will then get it'll
attach to the ribosome and it'll be read
and I'll start making all the proteins
that make up this virus it'll just
rapidly make this virus it also has a
protein that replicates chains of RNA
and it doesn't just replicate any chain
of RNA it replicates specifically chains
of RNA that have a special sequence in
them that all of the virus genes have so
it only replicate replicates viral
strands of RNA and so he the guy that
discovered this called that RNA
replicase and it is the enzyme that that
the early experimenters and RNA
evolution decided to use to allow RNA to
replicate we now have a bunch of
different ones that we use and a bunch
of different chemistry's that we use
again we're trying to get chemistry's
that are more and more similar to
chemistry's that would be found on the
early earth but in these early
experiments we were using these complex
proteins to allow RNA to evolve and that
complex protein came from this virus so
this first experiment go back to my
paper here this first experiment just
what what he did is he set up some test
tubes with
I really simplified chemistry of
something that it would find somewhat
similar to inside of a bacterial cell so
we set up a salinity to be similar and a
lot of the he he loaded it with RNA
nucleotides so single monomers of RNA
and he loaded it with chains of RNA that
had that specific viral sequence that
allowed them to be recognized by the RNA
replicase the protein that allows those
RNA chains to reproduce and then he
inserted the RNA replicase and what he
did is he just let them replicate
rapidly and then he would take a small
sample of the liquid that was produced
of the solution that was produced and he
would squirt that into a new vial and
let let things replicate in there and he
could just kept doing this over and over
and over again
he did that for forty times forty eight
forty inoculations is what they call it
when you inoculate a new a nice clean
batch of of material with your original
evolving strain and after forty
generations you know if you think about
what's happening here the natural
selection going on in this experiment
the nature here which is of course the
the inside of this this test tube that
environment is selecting for chains of
RNA that are better and better at
attracting that RNA replicase protein
and replicating rapidly and then doing
it again so he was selecting for super
rapid replication and what happened is
that after just after just forty
transfers his molecules were replicating
fifteen times faster than the original
molecules from the virus so he had a
rapid evolution towards really fast
replication and when he looked at the
structure of these rnas to see what it
was that they did how did they evolve
this super rapid replication it was
almost disappoint
how simple it was what they did did is
they just any mutation that made the RNA
shorter without ruining the stretch of
RNA that attracts the the replicase any
mutation that made them shorter made
them replicate faster and so not only
were they 15 times faster they were also
15 times shorter than the original
nucleotides and at first you know if
we're thinking you know we want this
process to be able to give rise to new
complexity all he did was make something
shorter you know that's how is that
evidence of evolution here right but he
pointed out in his first paper he writes
it should escape the attention I should
not escape the attention of the reader
that other selective stresses aside from
rapid replication other selective
stresses can be imposed on the system to
generate RNA entities which exaggerate
other molecular features so in other
words if we put obstacles in the way of
replication these RNA chains should
evolve new functions they should evolve
new complexities and by the way
experiments showed that they did but
this brings me to kind of a weird point
that I want to talk about here real
quick a quick aside there are two ways
of existing in the universe one way is
to be really hard like a rock in your
environment and if you are hard like a
rock you're going to persist in your
environment right so that's one way that
things can exist in our universe they
can be hard they can be really stable
within their environment another way to
be common in the universe is to just get
reproduced or produced really easily so
snowflakes on earth are a common example
of something that is fragile it doesn't
exist very long but they get produced so
often that they are actually really
common on planet earth snowflakes are
very common on planet earth so there are
these two ways to exist living
things are kind of a combination of both
we replicate rapidly and we're also
fairly resistant to degradation right
and different organisms have evolved
some have evolved to replicate super
quick but they're also very fragile and
his little RNA chains that he he created
through evolution and this I will do
evolution experiment they are examples
of these organisms that reproduce
extremely rapidly but are very very
fragile pretty much any any obstacle
that they come across they will die
these really simplified molecules that
he ended up evolving in there but they
are they replicate so rapidly that
that's okay right we are examples of
organisms that do both were we're very
stable yeah and my first live podcast I
I mentioned that you know we're sort of
just an extension of our balls or our
ovaries you know where we're all about
replication that's not totally true
because we're also about survival
we are very stable organisms and we wait
for the right time to replicate and so
basically what what he was saying that
after doing this first RNA replication
experiment he was saying in future
experiments we should give the RNA some
obstacles we should give it a reason to
wait before it replicates do other
things with science replication and he
believed that we can get it to evolve
complexity and sure enough he was right
in section 3 of this paper he goes on to
outline some other experiments that he
did where he would add weird obstacles
to these RNA chains as they were trying
to replicate so one of the things that
he did is he would starve them of
nutrients you know the types of
nutrients these chains need that they
need RNA nucleotides in order to
replicate that's what they make their
bodies out of
and it they needed other molecules and
he just deprived them of some of the
molecules that they needed for
replication and if he deprived them all
at once of those molecules they would
die so the the lineage would go extinct
but he if he slowly deprived them of
those molecules they would evolve and
adapt their sequences would change
through descent with modification acted
upon by selection their sequences would
change they would adapt and they would
be many times more efficient at survival
and reproduction without the the
molecules that the original chains of
RNA needed to replicate he also added
some toxins things that got in the way
of specifically of base pairing and
again it was the same thing if you added
too much of the toxin right away the
thing would go extinct if he added it
slowly the things would adapt they would
actually evolve to the obstacles that he
put in their way just so cool these
these experiments were so awesome he's
doing all of this just with RNA RNA
replicating again there's no genetic
code there's just you know he had to set
up a very specific environment for them
but there was no genetic code needed no
genetic code needed for this evolution
to occur and it and no cells needed so
the final thing that started happening
is we realized look these things are
evolving new traits new abilities in
ways that we can't even wait we have to
then study them to figure out how it was
that they they solve the problems that
we threw at them
evolution is come in coming up with very
sophisticated solutions to the problem
problems that we throw at it
I wonder how crazy we can get his the
other big experiment that they did is
they threw in a predator an RNAi
predator they throw in an enzyme called
RNA s in this particular RNAs it's
digested RNA by grabbing
the you nucleotides and the let's see
what was it these C nucleotides and the
U nucleotides if any of those
nucleotides were loose on an RNA chain
this enzyme would grab the RNA chain and
start to digest it so it was a it was an
RNA s-- it's a it's an enzyme that hunts
down chains of RNA and starts degrading
them by grabbing the C or you
nucleotides that are loose and starts
digesting them and he found this
structure right here that we see on the
page I'm not gonna go into the detail
about how this works but it evolved a
way to hide all of its loose C and loose
u nucleotides its structure evolved in a
way that could hide from this predator
and it could still replicate this is so
cool you have a predator that's just
made out of protein it's not actually a
full on living organism like we would
consider today and you have a chain of
RNA that's also we wouldn't really
consider it a full-on living organism
but it's acting like an organism it's
it's evolving ways to avoid a predator
this is so cool
just all in the test tube just right
before our very eyes all of this
happened and we know the actual sequence
we actually know the trick that that RNA
chain evolved to avoid its predator this
is just so cool then to top all of this
researchers said you know what evolution
is so good at finding novel solutions to
problems what if we trained through this
evolutionary process a chain of RNA what
if we evolved the chain of RNA that
could do complex medical things for us
that could what if we what if we evolved
a molecule that can bind specifically to
a protein in the body that's problematic
and use it as a medicine to actually fix
a real problem
sure enough we were able to do this
there is a disease that causes blindness
and old people so well let me just read
my notes here because I there's a lot of
vocabulary here that I'm not familiar
with so a process was used to invent a
medication Mew kitchen that's the name
of the medication which stops the
progression of a specific type of
macular degeneration so macular
degeneration is the type of blindness
that elderly people get it's you know
adult onset blindness and they actually
evolved a molecule that can it can't
restore sight but it can stop the
progression of blindness in elderly
people again it has to be a specific
type of this disease but can actually
stop the progression of this blindness
and it's a molecule that we evolved
through evolution RNA evolution
experiments since that this was one of
the earliest molecules that was evolved
the earliest medications that was
evolved in this way since then we've
we've done very similar things to evolve
all sorts of different types of
molecules imatinib is a molecule that
was also evolved not through a process
exactly the same we we used a selection
process we had it we we built this
machine that kid mutate molecules that
aren't chains of RNA commute mutate
pretty much any type of a molecule and
it would just through it through an
evolutionary trial and error process it
would just change a molecule slightly
and test that against its its medical
target then mutated it again slightly
test it again it's it's tested again
against his target and so on and so
forth until we we found a mat to nip
this molecule that's used to treat
chronic myelogenous leukemia very
specific type of leukemia and just
recently you know we started using this
to treat leukemia years ago in just this
year a paper was was published saying
that imatinib not only does it treat
this type of
cancer it can actually cure it people
who have been using the medication for
five to ten years a lot of times when we
take them off the medication we find
that the disease has been completely
cured we have now used evolution to cure
cancer all right
Darwin's theory of evolution has
literally allowed us to heal the sick
give a sight to the blind or at least
stop the progression of blindness and
cure cancer right this is insane
so anyway
very impressive these experiments I just
want to end things here by opening up to
questions once more if people have any
and again super chats are welcome folks
this is the time of the podcast where I
play the organ music and pass around the
collection plate you know on this Sunday
morning science broadcast
Brian Stevens can you are you asking the
question there assume you mean yeah
rewrite that please someone says is it
true that we can eventually slow down or
reverse the aging process maybe the
problem with aging is we don't have a
good theory of aging that is fully
worked out a lot of people think that
aging has to do with avoiding cancer we
kill we start killing cells when they
start accumulating mutations they
actually cells will commit suicide as
they accumulate mutations in order to
avoid producing cancer and the this
process is one of the things that we
think we think causes aging and in order
to kind of reverse engineer that is
going to be extremely complex so a lot
of these a lot of the the if we want to
actually edit our genes and edit
mutations for example that crop up in
our bodies as we're growing and maturing
we have to find a way to edit all of the
cells in our body at the same time we
need a delivery system to to deliver
things like you know if we end up using
CRISPR to do it or whatever and these
delivery systems are really hard that's
one of the big holdups that we're having
so even if we do really understand aging
to the point to where we could correct
it we also need to find a way to
actually you know deliver gene editing
technologies to all of the cells in our
bodies so it's probably possible
hypothetically but we're a long way away
from it and there's gonna be a lot of
problems with it I'm sure that we'll
have to work out
okay Brian Stephen says assuming you
mean topoisomerase to inhibitors as a
leukemia killer so that a Matt to name
is actually a really small molecule tiny
little molecule it goes and it attacks
it gums up a protein that as a result of
the mutation that gives rise to this
specific type of loop of myelogenous
leukemia so it's there's a there's a
chromosome fusion in this type of
leukemia that creates a really weird
protein and this molecule gums up that
protein whether or not that's the
protein that you you said there or not I
don't know I'd have to look that up but
yeah
someone says when we'll be able when
we'll be able to cure low IQ asking for
a friend
yeah I I don't know it looks like that
is kind of it for questions hopefully
everybody was able to follow this
conversation I know it was sort of
difficult if you haven't watched the RNA
videos or thought much about RNA
replication or what you know the RNA
world hypothesis but this is really cool
stuff really really neat stuff that the
research that's been going on in this is
absolutely insane the things that we've
been able to do since what sense
understanding how life works how genes
work is really really amazing someone
asked can you explain why RNA is the
most plausible hypothesis RNA is not
necessarily the most plausible
hypothesis but it's it's the the route
that it's the molecule that it looks
like was really important for several
reasons one is that the ribosome which
is this really complex molecule that
takes chains of RNA and reads them out
into protein the ribosome is made of RNA
so unlike other enzymes in our body
which are made of protein it's made of
RNA and it's one of the most fundamental
you know molecules in our body it does
have some protein in it but the proteins
in the ribosome are just used to
stabilize the molecule all the
functional bits of the ribosome are made
of RNA so that was one of the big clues
the other big clue is that RNA can act
both as a reproducing molecule it can
act as a template for its own
replication and it can also fold up and
act as an enzyme and it's that dual
property of a
molecule that makes it really promising
for the original evolving entity now RNA
itself is fairly complex its nucleotides
are fairly fragile and it has to be in
chain like form in order to start to
replicate right and there also needs an
enzyme that can help it replicate or
catalyst I can help it replicate so we
don't think that it was the original
thing that evolved there's a separate
type of evolution called chemical
evolution which works a little bit
differently there's not descent with
modification so much as there is
repetitive
production and an evolving chemical
system and I would need it another cup
of coffee to go into that right now
that's kind of a topic for another day
but there's a really good paper I'll
link to it in the video description on
the the metabolism first hypothesis so
it's believed that a metabolism actually
evolved a metabolic system evolved first
that gave rise to RNA which could
actually replicate through this these
this template template directed
replication that type of replication
eventually gave rise to the ribosome and
eventually we get living cells and
everything from that today so but yeah
another topic for another day
someone asks so if it's not the most
plausible than it is it is it because of
the dual purpose that makes the
hypothesis that makes it the hypothesis
that scientists mainly subscribes you I
wouldn't say it says the hypothesis that
people mainly subscribe to it's the one
that's getting the most research done
and it's for multiple reasons first of
all is that dual the dual properties of
RNA but also the the fact that RNA is
used in every single organism today and
in every virus you know it's it's super
prevalent in life today the reason that
I say it's not the the only plausible
solution or necessarily the most
plausible solution is because it is a
complex molecule even its monomers are
complex and they're not very stable in
environments that we would imagine
existed on the early earth but there are
so Nicolas HUD who works at the Center
for chemical evolution he is studying
alternatives to RNA that are similar to
our na but are more stable and more
readily produced in an early Earth
environment they could have transitioned
into RNA so so there's that type of
research that's happening too that's why
I say it's not necessarily the most most
probable but all of the experiments that
we do on how RNA on how early evolution
would have happened we use RNA because
again it's in cells today it's what the
ribosome is made of and we already have
all this technology for sequencing
chains of RNA we already have all the
equipment to study RNA so there's lots
of reasons RNA is used in life origins
research Junior JR poon did a super chat
thank you just want to say I love your
channel and live topics so cool thanks I
appreciate it
we've got one more question is it
possible that we could evolve RNA that
could evolve without a catalyst I think
if you slowly remove the catalyst from
the environment it might be able to
happen
you do need a catalyst but
there's some newer research and if you
look at this ends are the metabolism
first hypothesis they're looking at
really really simple catalysts
so in experiments that we read about we
learn about today we're using a complex
catalyst that's a protein you know it's
an enzyme but much simpler catalysts can
also do the job given the right
environmental circumstances and if we
have an evolving metabolic system we
could get something like this to happen
there are also experiments on enzymes
made of RNA itself so these and actually
this paper the 40 years of evolutionary
experiments that paper actually goes on
to talk specifically about the evolution
of RNA enzymes so a chain of RNA that
can replicate other chains of our name
it's that backbone binding process
that's that's hard to do and people are
trying to evolve these RNA chains that
can do that but it it's kind of a
chicken and egg scenario you know it you
could evolve in RNA chain that can do
that but you need to use evolution to
produce that and you can't get evolution
to happen without that the replication
so this this metabolism first study is
really I think where the money is at for
understanding the origin of life the
understanding the origin of the RNA
world right so there's that
okay I'm gonna close things out with
that thank you for watching this has
been a lot of fun hopefully you enjoyed
going through this paper if you'd like
me to do if you have ideas for future
topics let me know I think that next
week I'm going to talk about the
evolution of mimicry
I just produced the video for the stated
casually channel on snake mimicry which
you should watch that was just published
yesterday and yeah so long for now stay
curious a lot of fun